Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec. Pour ce cinquième épisode, j'ai passé septante minutes avec mon ami Nicolas Roland.
Jusqu'à cet été, Nicolas était chercheur en sciences de l'éducation à l'Université Libre de Bruxelles, où il dirigeait l'unité ULB Podcast, qui est chargée d'accompagner les enseignants dans leur transition vers le numérique.
Ensemble, on parle de l'enseignement en Belgique et de ses difficultés à évoluer et des solutions que le numérique peut éventuellement lui offrir.
Bonne écoute. Et bonjour à tous. On est ici pour un nouvel épisode avec Nicolas Roland. Nicolas, salut.
Bonjour.
Tu es chercheur à l'ULB en sciences de l'éducation. Est-ce que tu peux expliquer à nos auditeurs ce que tu fais dans la vie ?
Donc oui, je suis chercheur en sciences de l'éducation. En tout cas, c'est ce qui est sur mon contrat. Alors la recherche, je la fais plutôt le soir et la nuit, mais ça, j'en parlerai après.
Ce que je fais de mes journées, c'est que je dirige ULB Podcast, qui est la cellule d'innovation en pédagogie numérique à l'Université Libre de Bruxelles.
Et donc on accompagne les enseignants de l'université, mais également des institutions publiques et privées extérieures dans l'utilisation du numérique à des fins de formation ou d'éducation.
C'est intéressant parce qu'on sait justement que le milieu de l'enseignement, l'institution scolaire, de manière générale, est plutôt à la traîne, plutôt inerte, plutôt statique pour toutes les questions de numérique ou même pour autre chose.
Alors, quand on prend une photographie globale du paysage, c'est ce qu'on voit. C'est que de manière générale, ça a l'air plutôt l'encéphalogramme plat.
Il se passe pas beaucoup de choses. Mais aujourd'hui, je dirais que ce sont surtout des actions de personnes qui innovent dans leur coin et qu'on va aider, qu'on va soutenir.
Et par nos actions également, on va évaluer leurs travaux, leurs idées, leurs innovations, évaluer les effets sur leurs étudiants pour essayer de passer les bonnes pratiques à d'autres enseignants.
Donc certes, dans la photographie globale,
on voit pas beaucoup de choses, mais il y a quand même beaucoup d'enseignants qui, au sein de leur classe, en primaire, en secondaire, dans le supérieur ou même dans des formateurs en entreprise qui,
qui innovent, qui utilisent le numérique.
Et nous, on va juste les accompagner, leur donner plus de capacité à utiliser ce numérique pour un meilleur apprentissage de leurs apprenants, leurs étudiants.
Et on va évaluer toutes leurs innovations pour voir celles qui ont le plus d'impact.
Donc en t'écoutant, on a finalement l'impression que c'est plus des actions
isolées de quelques innovateurs, quelques, voilà, quelques personnes qui cherchent à révolutionner le truc, mais à petite échelle, plus qu'une grande révolution qui est en train de se faire
à l'échelle de tout le secteur.
Malheureusement, oui. Alors, c'est en train de changer, mais je dirais que ce qui s'est passé jusqu'à aujourd'hui, et notamment dans l'enseignement obligatoire,
c'est que l'argent qui a été mis par le pouvoir politique a été surtout proposé sur le matériel.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a eu des plans cyberclasse, cyberécole. Ensuite, on a eu des tableaux blancs interactifs, des tablettes.
Bref, il y a beaucoup d'argent qui est mis dans ce matériel. Ce matériel arrive dans les classes. Malheureusement, il y a très peu d'accompagnement des enseignants à l'utilisation de ce matériel,
aux pratiques qui peuvent être plus efficaces dans l'utilisation de ce matériel.
Et donc ceux qui vont utiliser l'ensemble de ces outils, ben ce sont ceux qui se sentent capables de les utiliser.
Et souvent, c'est un parcours qui est assez long. On a quelques enseignants qui ont des compétences peut-être pas innées, mais qui, par un côté parfois geek, parfois technophile, maîtrisent ou maîtrisent rapidement les outils numériques.
À côté de ça, c'est surtout des enseignants qui vont accepter de se former en formation continue, qui vont se former par différents canaux pour acquérir les compétences nécessaires à l'usage de ces outils.
Et donc ça, ça prend vraiment du temps. Et malheureusement, là, je veux dire, la manière dont ça se passe, c'est que le matériel est mis parfois sans concertation avec les enseignants.
Dans les différentes casquettes professionnelles que j'ai, l'une de celles-ci est d'être professeur invité dans une année de spécialisation qui forme des enseignants en fonction à l'usage des technologies.
Et chaque année, on a des enseignants qui arrivent à notre soirée un peu portes ouvertes où on explique le programme de cette année.
Donc, on a des enseignants qui arrivent en nous expliquant : « Parti au mois de juin en vacances, j'avais mon tableau vert.
Je suis revenu, j'ai, dans le meilleur des cas, un tableau vert, mais surtout, j'ai un tableau blanc interactif et je ne sais pas comment l'utiliser.
Donc, je viens me former chez vous. »
Donc vraiment des investissements sur le matériel, sur, voilà, les outils à disposition des enseignants, mais pas sur leur emploi, sur comment c'est censé permettre un meilleur enseignement.
Est-ce que cette situation-là, elle est spécifique à la Belgique francophone ou bien c'est quelque chose qu'on observe partout dans le monde ?
Est-ce que la Belgique est particulièrement à la traîne à ce niveau-là ?
Mais je dirais que de manière générale, on est à la traîne et on a le défaut de pas prendre exemple sur les pays qui sont en avance.
'Fin, de les prendre pour exemple, mais pas tirer les bonnes conclusions, oui, par rapport à leurs expériences.
Et on peut voir, par exemple, en Angleterre, dans le système scolaire anglais, ils ont équipé plus de cent pour cent de leurs classes de tableaux blancs interactifs.
Quand je dis plus de cent pour cent, c'est que parfois, il y en avait plusieurs dans une classe. Ça a été vraiment un raz de marée.
Finalement, ils en sont très vite revenus par tout un tas de raisons, les manques d'adoption, mais également des résultats qui n'étaient pas à la hauteur des attentes.
Et finalement, de notre côté, ces dernières années, nous, on n'a pas pris ça comme expérience et on a équipé de notre côté les écoles en tableaux blancs interactifs.
Donc c'est quelque chose-
On peut peut-être juste rappeler à nos auditeurs, un tableau blanc interactif, c'est grosso modo une espèce de tableau où on va pouvoir projeter l'image d'un PC et c'est aussi un écran tactile où on va pouvoir
dessiner par-dessus l'image qui est projetée.
Voilà, et on va pouvoir dessiner beaucoup plus facilement, faire des recherches sur Internet, mais utiliser ses mains.
Je dirais même que c'est presque comme une grosse, une grande tablette qui est au mur et que l'enseignant et les élèves peuvent utiliser.
Et donc ça coûte super cher.
Ça coûte beaucoup plus cher qu'un tableau vert.
Puisque tu évoques le sujet, j'ai envie de te poser la question. Je sais que la Région bruxelloise est venue vers ULB Podcast pour avoir un rapport sur l'emploi des tableaux blancs interactifs dans les écoles et sur leur utilité.
Je pense que tu as rendu ce rapport et que ça n'a pas été super bien reçu. Tu peux nous parler de cette expérience ?
Alors, d'abord, parler des conclusions du rapport et finalement, ça explique pas mal la situation
aujourd'hui et le rapport parfois entre la recherche et le politique et même l'instrumentalisation parfois des actions par le politique.
D'abord, donc, les conclusions. Dans les grandes lignes, ce qu'on a remarqué, c'est que malgré
des investissements qui ont été importants par la Ville de Bruxelles en matériel informatique, tableaux blancs interactifs, tablettes, etc., dans les écoles, on peut remarquer qu'il y a un usage qui reste très faible.
Lorsque l'usage est présent, je dirais quantitativement, c'est pour des activités qui sont peut-être pas de pauvre qualité, ce serait un grand mot, mais juste de substitution.
On utilise le tableau blanc interactif comme on utilisait le tableau vert sans utiliser les plus-values que ce tableau blanc interactif peut apporter.
Donc, voilà, des usages qui restent assez faibles, si ce n'est quelques, encore une fois, quelques fulgurances, quelques innovateurs au sein des écoles.
Et un des résultats les plus marquants, c'est que seuls 10 % des enseignants se sentaient capables d'utiliser le numérique dans les conditions actuelles, c'est-à-dire sans aucune formation et sans accompagnement.
Au-delà de ça, 40 % des enseignants se disaient capables normalement d'utiliser le numérique s'ils étaient accompagnés ou formés et surtout 50 % des enseignants se
disaient être incapables, enfin, se sentaient incapables d'utiliser le numérique, même s'ils étaient formés et même s'ils étaient accompagnés.
Donc c'est quand même un chiffre assez important.
Se sentaient fondamentalement limités, comme quoi ils n'y arriveraient jamais, même si on les aidait.
Voilà, c'est vraiment en termes de sentiment d'efficacité personnelle. Eux se disaient qu'ils n'y arriveraient jamais, même s'ils étaient aidés, formés, etc.
Est-ce que les professeurs bruxellois sont particulièrement hermétiques à la transition numérique ? Est-ce que c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'ils ne peuvent pas intégrer ?
Non, je dirais que ça se retrouve dans pas mal de régions du monde. Et une des dimensions particulières, c'est qu'on remarque que la formation a un impact sur les pratiques pédagogiques.
Donc, pour le résumer un peu caricaturalement, les enseignants ont tendance à former de la même manière qu'ils ont eux-mêmes été formés.
C'est-à-dire que si on n'a pas vu des pratiques d'utilisation du numérique durant sa formation, on va avoir tendance soi-même à ne pas utiliser du numérique par la suite.
Et donc, y a une sorte de cercle vicieux qui se retrouve-
'Fin, y a une certaine culture de l'émulation, en fait.
Voilà, et un cercle vicieux qui se retrouve partout à ce niveau-là. Donc, je reviens sur mon histoire avec le politique.
Ces résultats n'étaient, selon nous, pas mauvais. Encore une fois, ils étaient assez similaires à ce qu'on peut retrouver dans d'autres régions du monde.
Et pour moi, ils avaient aussi un apport social, c'est de dire : « OK, on a ces résultats, qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire pour agir ?
» D'ailleurs, dans ce rapport, on a proposé des pistes
d'action et des recommandations. Et donc, c'était pas en soi un mauvais rapport, mais la Ville de Bruxelles a eu des difficultés quant aux résultats, a eu des difficultés à accepter ces résultats.
Et voyait là-dedans un ratage, en quelque sorte. On a investi de l'argent et on n'a pas les résultats escomptés.
Et ça, ça se retrouve assez souvent, je dirais, dans les liens entre la recherche et leur bailleur de fonds.
C'est le fait que les bailleurs de fonds attendent certains résultats et sont déçus s'ils n'ont pas ces résultats, et notamment lorsqu'on travaille autour de l'efficacité.
Et je dirais, au-delà des bailleurs de fonds, ce qu'on peut remarquer, c'est que les étudiants eux-mêmes, lorsqu'ils sont
dans leurs études de master en sciences de l'éducation et qu'ils font des hypothèses autour de l'efficacité d'une méthode pédagogique ou d'outils numériques, ils vont avoir tendance à se dire
: « J'espère que mon hypothèse sera vérifiée, que la méthode, l'outil aura un impact significatif sur l'apprentissage.
» Mais en soi, lorsqu'on a une hypothèse qui est non vérifiée, qu'on a un impact non significatif, on voit que l'outil ou la méthode n'a pas de résultat,
c'est un résultat, c'est un résultat pertinent et c'est un résultat qu'il faut pouvoir analyser,
utiliser pour les prochaines étapes.
Malheureusement, c'est ça la science. Et entre la science et l'utilisation politique de cette science, ben y a,
y a parfois un gap et une mauvaise compréhension autour de laquelle on a travaillé avec la Ville de Bruxelles et en travaillant sur ces recommandations.
Mais je dirais qu'en effet, au départ, on a eu des discussions sur ces résultats en se demandant si c'était un mauvais rapport, est-ce que ça donnait une mauvaise image des enseignants.
Non, ce sont des résultats, il faut les utiliser, les analyser et en tirer des conclusions.
On sait qu'il y a une grande réforme qui se prépare à la fois du côté francophone et néerlandophone en Belgique. En particulier ici, on va parler du côté francophone avec le Pacte d'excellence.
On en parle depuis longtemps. On entend des petites infos de temps en temps qui sortent dans la presse. On a entendu à un moment donné que le redoublement n'allait plus être possible.
On a entendu que le latin allait devenir obligatoire pour tout le monde jusqu'à la troisième secondaire. Y a aussi, je pense, dans ce Pacte d'excellence, des questions d'intégrer les outils numériques au sein de l'école.
Est-ce que tu peux nous parler un petit peu de ce qui se trame, de ce qui se prépare à ce niveau-là ?
Une des choses que j'observe qui me semble positive, c'est qu'on remet d'une part l'apprenant au centre, c'est-à-dire qu'on parle beaucoup plus de l'élève, de son usage de la technologie,
d'amener l'élève à lui-même utiliser la technologie dans ses apprentissages, alors qu'avant, on était très centré sur l'outil pédagogique, l'utilisation de l'outil juste par l'enseignant, comme si ce,
cet outil pédagogique allait révolutionner, que ce soit le tableau blanc interactif, encore une fois, ou un autre outil allait révolutionner ces pratiques.
Aujourd'hui, on parle beaucoup plus d'un usage du numérique par les élèves pour les amener aussi à développer une littératie numérique.
Être capable d'utiliser les outils numériques, non pas uniquement en apprenant le code, la programmation, etc.,
mais également en utilisant ces outils numériques dans leurs différents cours, en apprenant à utiliser des outils numériques en français pour publier, donc en apprenant les manières de publier sur le web, etc. Et dans-
De manière plus transversale quoi.
Voilà, une utilisation transversale du numérique, pas cantonnée à un cours, mais bien à différents cours et également une utilisation plus centrée sur les élèves et également avec les enseignants, mais beaucoup plus centrée sur les élèves.
Pour moi, ces dimensions-là sont importantes et sont un changement de paradigme, alors qu'avant, l'intégration du numérique était surtout centrée sur l'enseignant et le renforcement de l'enseignant.
Autre chose qui se dégage, c'est une volonté d'avoir une sorte de seuil numérique minimum au sein de toutes les écoles.
Et plutôt que d'avoir ce qu'on a aujourd'hui, des écoles très bien équipées et d'autres écoles beaucoup moins bien équipées, que ce soit en termes de réseau Internet, de matériel, c'est d'avoir un pack commun pour l'ensemble des écoles.
Ça me semble important pour avoir, pour limiter les inégalités. Après, je dirais que ça reste une réforme très importante.
Ça reste une réforme qui a un processus vertueux au départ. C'est le processus de la concertation, c'est d'écouter l'ensemble des acteurs, c'est de travailler avec l'ensemble des acteurs.
Et on le sait, dans le monde de l'enseignement, les acteurs ont-
Beaucoup de conservatisme.
Notamment, mais j'allais dire, il y a aussi des acteurs qui ont plus de poids. Il y a des acteurs qui, voilà, n'acceptent pas nécessairement facilement de changer leur position, etc.
Et donc à ce niveau-là, ça,
ça prend du temps. Et j'ai l'impression, encore une fois, c'est un avis plus personnel, mais que ce grand
changement, ce grand Pacte d'excellence se fera plutôt un ensemble de petites réformes plutôt qu'un changement qui va vraiment tout transcender.
Mais quand je dis que ça va être un ensemble de réformes et même si on le commence dans les prochains mois, prochaines années, il y a un ensemble de choses qui vont pas changer du jour au lendemain.
Un allongement de la formation des enseignants. Tous les enseignants vont pas tout d'un coup faire une année complémentaire, du moins les enseignants en fonction.
Pour les nouveaux, certes, ça va se mettre en place, mais c'est-à-dire qu'il va y avoir un temps de régulation sur le temps de carrière des enseignants qui sont déjà en fonction s'ils ne sont pas eux-mêmes formés.
Il va déjà y avoir ce temps-là. Si là-dedans venaient des matières complémentaires comme l'introduction du numérique, etc.
Il faut voir que cette introduction du numérique, elle va prendre du temps pour que ça se lisse sur l'ensemble des enseignants.
Donc voilà, c'est juste se dire, même si la réforme se met en œuvre, le temps qu'on en voit les effets, ça va prendre du temps.
Certains vont se voir directement arrêter le redoublement, c'est quasi instantané si la ministre et si le Pacte d'excellence le souhaite.
Maintenant, ça va pas... 'fin, au-delà d'un effet comme ça qui peut se faire quasi du jour au lendemain, il y a un ensemble d'autres actions qui vont prendre du temps, équiper de manière minimum les écoles.
Ça va prendre du temps.
C'est une grande machine. C'est une grande machine. La faire évoluer de manière plus subtile, ça va prendre du temps.
Voilà. Et parce qu'on est avec un ensemble d'acteurs humains qui ont leur considération propre, qui ont parfois, en effet, un certain conservatisme, mais qui ont aussi surtout besoin de formation, d'accompagnement.
Et même si des équipes d'accompagnement sont mises en place et autour du numérique, il y en a qui sont en train d'être mises en place, elles vont pas pouvoir tout d'un coup accompagner tous les enseignants de Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles.
Donc, ça va prendre du temps pour que ça se fasse.
Quelque chose qui me frappe pour comparer par exemple avec la France,
c'est que nous, on a un système scolaire très décentralisé avec plusieurs réseaux et certains diront
plusieurs écoles de pensée, alors qu'en France, ils ont vraiment le ministère de l'Éducation, le même examen, le même baccalauréat à passer dans toutes les écoles.
Ici, en Belgique, c'est beaucoup plus décentralisé. On a les écoles du réseau libre qui sont, dans les faits, en très grande majorité les écoles catholiques.
On a les écoles du réseau confessionnel, du réseau communal, provincial. C'est vraiment tout un bordel. C'est assez compliqué à suivre quand on s'y intéresse.
La question que j'ai envie de poser, c'est
: qu'est-ce que ça fait, puisque donc j'ai pas précisé, mais les écoles catholiques sont très dominantes en Belgique, puisque je crois deux Flamands sur trois sont issus de l'école catholique et un Wallon sur deux.
La question que j'ai envie de poser, c'est : quel est l'impact d'un enseignement qui n'est pas aussi laïque que celui de nos pays voisins ?
Et l'enseignement majoritairement catholique, quel est son impact sur notre culture, sur notre population, finalement ?
C'est une question particulièrement difficile, du moins de mon point de vue.
Oui, très politisée et très biaisée. Tu n'auras pas mieux une réponse qu'un autre, je crois.
Non, et puis je suis pas expert du domaine. Ce que je dirais avant tout, c'est que le fait d'avoir cette diversité, ces différents réseaux, crée aussi le conservatisme dont on parlait.
Parce qu'on est dans un système qu'on appelle de quasi-marché, c'est-à-dire qu'on est comme sur un marché financier et chaque école se positionne
et chaque réseau derrière se positionne par rapport à ses potentiels clients, aux parents qui vont choisir
l'école de leur enfant, etc.
Alors, choisir dans la mesure du possible, on connaît aujourd'hui les décrets qui limitent certains choix. Mais donc, il y a un choix qui se fait derrière ça.
Donc les écoles se positionnent. Et je dirais qu'on est passé d'un système de justice sociale où le libre choix
était présent pour que les parents puissent choisir l'école la plus adaptée à leur enfant, à un système de quasi-marché où les écoles se font de la concurrence entre elles,
où certaines écoles vont avoir tendance à essayer d'attirer les meilleurs élèves, mais en disant aux parents : « Ben il y a un prix à payer, il y a des voyages scolaires, il y a du matériel, il y a ceci.
» Et où on a d'autres écoles qui vont plutôt avoir tendance à essayer d'avoir un maximum d'élèves pour avoir plus d'enseignants, plus de budget, etc.
Et donc dans ce système de quasi-marché, lorsqu'on souhaite implanter des changements et des changements organisationnels, des changements structurels, par exemple, proposer un tronc commun, on va voir que ça crée un certain conservatisme.
Tout le monde ne va pas dans une direction qui est commune, tout le monde joue à son niveau, chaque réseau joue sa place et son positionnement et à la limite chaque école joue également son positionnement.
Donc je dirais qu'avant tout, le fait d'avoir ces dimensions-là crée un certain conservatisme. Après, l'impact des écoles catholiques sur l'enseignement-
Sur la culture
...et sur la culture, beh, c'est d'une part un peu lié parce que vu qu'on est dans un marché concurrentiel, il faut pouvoir se démarquer des autres écoles, des autres réseaux.
C'est-à-dire, dans la pensée populaire, l'école catholique est une école plus efficace, plus efficiente, où on obtient de meilleurs résultats, qui prépare mieux, notamment à l'université.
Ça vient de ces dimensions-là.
Et derrière, j'dirais que
il peut y avoir certaines pratiques pédagogiques qui vont être tournées moins vers l'ouverture dans les écoles catholiques que dans d'autres écoles, mais j'dirais que là, c'est peut-être marginal et je voudrais pas entrer sur un terrain où
Non, tu l'as déjà fait, vas-y, chante.
Où tout d'un coup, on va dire : « Ah,
il a dit ça. » Non, ça représente une diversité, mais j'crois qu'aujourd'hui, la diversité, ça devrait être de pouvoir clairement choisir son enseignement sans avoir de confession et d'avoir une possibilité
d'un enseignement confessionnel sur certains aspects, mais j'dirais dans toutes les écoles.
Et surtout que cette dimension n'impacte pas les programmes d'enseignement parce qu'aujourd'hui, le fait d'être dans un réseau va impacter les programmes d'enseignement.
Donc pour le dire plus clairement pour les auditeurs, il y a la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles qui définit ce qu'on appelle des compétences et les compétences terminales, notamment dans l'enseignement secondaire.
C'est-à-dire quel est le niveau, et quel savoir, savoir-être, savoir-faire, les étudiants, les élèves doivent être capables de mobiliser lorsqu'ils arrivent à certains moments de leur scolarité, surtout à la fin de leur scolarité.
Cette dimension-là est éditée par la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles pour l'ensemble des écoles, mais derrière, les programmes, c'est-à-dire la manière d'y arriver, ce qui doit être enseigné,
la manière d'enseigner, les méthodes qui sont utilisées, parfois certains contenus,
vont être laissés à la libre appréciation des réseaux,
à travers les programmes de ces réseaux et également parfois même aux écoles sur les méthodes liées à certaines écoles.
Et là, ça va entraîner de l'inégalité et aussi des dimensions qui, pour moi, peuvent être problématiques.
Et cette décentralisation, encore une fois, elle peut être vue,
on peut voir le verre à moitié plein. C'est-à-dire, oui, ça permet à chaque parent de choisir une école où les méthodes pédagogiques ou le programme est plus adapté à son enfant qu'une autre école, etc.
Mais par le manque d'information aux parents, par la difficulté que c'est aujourd'hui pour les parents de choisir une école, ça va créer plus d'inégalités entre les familles.
Et c'est ça que je reproche. Donc c'est pas nécessairement le fait qu'il y ait un enseignement catholique.
Non, c'est pas le message qu'on essaie de faire passer.
Mais c'est également toutes les dimensions qu'il peut y avoir derrière, d'avoir des réseaux. Même si pour l'enseignement catholique, alors j'ai pas fait des analyses de programmes ces dernières années,
mais à l'époque de mes études de master qui remontent aux années 2008, 2010,
pour avoir travaillé autour de l'enseignement de l'évolution, on pouvait voir des aspects particulièrement importants et des différences importantes entre ce qui était enseigné dans les programmes de
De l'évolution au sens créationniste.
Oui, oui, oui. L'évolution en science, et des dimensions qui n'étaient pas du tout vues dans les écoles catholiques.
Alors, c'est peut-être une caricature et j'espère que ça a changé, mais c'était présent dans ces années-là et on conseillait de pas voir certaines dimensions de l'évolution ou de passer outre.
On conseillait, tu parles du-
Le programme, le programme.
Le programme du-
Le réseau de l'enseignement libre confessionnel.
C'est ça. Le SeGEC, c'est ça ?
Oui.
C'est ça, oui. Mais j'aimerais rebondir là-dessus puisqu'on sait que
dans l'enseignement, les manuels scolaires sont un outil très important, une plateforme très importante pour permettre aux enseignants de bien faire leur métier.
On m'a fait remarquer qu'en Belgique, les maisons d'édition de manuels scolaires étaient, corrige-moi si je me trompe, mais étaient catholiques.
Il n'y avait pas finalement une maison d'édition de manuels scolaires qui représenterait, par exemple, les mêmes idées que l'Université Libre de Bruxelles, libres penseurs, etc.
Est-ce qu'on n'est pas là aussi dans une question d'idéologie, de, bah oui, de les questions de l'évolution, les questions de la place de la femme dans la société, ces sujets-là.
On sait que parfois, les enseignants travaillent avec des photocopies de manuels qui datent d'il y a plusieurs décennies.
Et on retrouve souvent dans ces manuels scolaires des trucs du style, tu sais, les petits problèmes pour les-- maman fait la vaisselle, elle fait couler deux litres d'eau, combien de temps doit-elle attendre ?
Et puis papa travaille, il rentre du boulot, il conduit sa voiture, combien d'essence, voilà, etc. Est-ce que je touche à un problème dans l'enseignement belge ou pas du tout ?
Alors, il y a pas mal de soucis dans ce que tu évoques. Alors, pas le fait d'évoquer ça, mais dans cette histoire des manuels scolaires.
Je pourrais malheureusement pas te contredire ou affirmer que tu as raison concernant les maisons d'édition de manuels scolaires.
J'en sais rien. Je suis pas spécialiste dans les manuels scolaires. Mais l'idée de manuels scolaires, ce qui est clair par rapport à ce que tu disais, c'est que pour moi, l'idée même de manuels scolaires
va à l'encontre d'un enseignement tel qu'il peut être pensé, réfléchi, proposé à l'Université Libre de Bruxelles où
la dimension principale, c'est le libre examen, donc d'apprendre à être critique et à remettre les choses en question.
Et le manuel scolaire, c'est finalement l'antithèse de ça.
C'est une forme de dogmatisme.
Oui, et de recettes de cuisine de l'enseignement.
De prêt-à-penser.
Oui, de prêt-à-penser ou de prêt-à-enseigner. Et donc c'est la dimension qui me pose
problème dans le manuel scolaire, c'est que très souvent, c'est une recette à appliquer avec des exemples, des exercices, une manière d'expliquer la théorie, etc.
Qui est forcément un petit peu biaisée, qui vient forcément d'une certaine façon de penser-
Voilà et donc-
Qui est faite pour être reproduite.
Oui, et donc y a déjà des choix qui sont opérés dans les contenus, mais même ce qu'on appelle la transposition didactique, c'est-à-dire le passage d'un savoir savant, d'un savoir scientifique en un savoir enseignable.
Y a toujours un travail de transposition. Lui aussi, il est fait de choix, de références qu'on prend ou qu'on ne prend pas.
Et donc ça entraîne cette dimension problématique qu'on donne à un savoir prêt à, encore une fois, prêt à enseigner, prêt à apprendre.
Et c'est donc la dimension de manuel scolaire, pour moi, qui est, qui peut être critiquable.
Donc c'est finalement normal qu'on ne puisse pas trouver un équivalent libre penseur aux maisons d'édition catholiques puisque tu as l'air de dire que ça va à l'encontre des fondamentaux...
On pourra avoir des manuels qui amènent à
eux-mêmes faire des choix sur certaines thématiques et enseigner les différentes dimensions,
d'un savoir en particulier, les différents positionnements, différentes postures, alors que souvent dans les manuels scolaires, on va faire un choix en particulier et puis on va dire que c'est ce choix qui est à enseigner.
Et souvent, malheureusement, ce choix n'est pas explicité dans le manuel lui-même.
La pédagogie que tu décris ici, où on n'est finalement pas complètement dépendant d'un manuel scolaire, où on enseigne l'esprit critique, etc.
Est-ce que c'est représenté dans les faits ici en Belgique ? Ou est-ce que c'est quelque chose de rare ? Est-ce qu'on peut le trouver ?
Si moi-même, j'ai envie d'envoyer, je sais pas, mon fils un jour dans une école qui répond à ces critères-là, est-ce que ça existe vraiment ou est-ce que c'est plus un fantasme de chercheur à l'université qui est complètement en
décalage avec la réalité ?
Y a déjà un ensemble d'écoles qui sont plutôt dans le réseau libre, non confessionnel.
Ah, c'est très rare, ça. C'est très très rare. Elles sont très très minoritaires.
Mais on en a quand même quelques-unes.
Y en a combien à Bruxelles ?
J'ai plus les chiffres en tête.
Deux ?
Non, non, y en a
quelques-unes. Mais à côté de ça, y a même dans le réseau officiel des écoles qui proposent ce qu'on appelle des pédagogies alternatives,
donc des pédagogies qui vont être beaucoup plus centrées sur l'élève et la construction du savoir par l'élève.
Aujourd'hui, malheureusement, on reste dans une pédagogie qui est transmissive. On transmet un contenu, on voit l'élève comme un verre vide qu'il faut remplir.
Et donc l'enseignant déverse son savoir, parfois en exerçant un peu pour faire plaisir à l'élève, pour le tenir réveillé en lui donnant quelques exercices.
Mais on reste dans une dimension très transmissive du contenu et puis dans du drill. C'est-à-dire, on réussit, on rate, on donne des exercices très segmentés.
Et malheureusement, on ne regarde pas la dimension
globale du savoir. Et ce que proposent les pédagogies alternatives, c'est de
plus amener l'élève à construire lui-même le savoir, à faire de la recherche autour des dimensions à savoir et à utiliser le produit de ses recherches pour arriver à ses fins.
Plutôt que d'enseigner l'orthographe, d'enseigner la grammaire, d'enseigner la composition, c'est de demander from scratch, en quelque sorte, à un élève de dire : « Bah, fais une composition.
Ah ben c'est quoi ? Ou fais, je sais pas,
un argumentaire sur tel élément.
Je sais pas, ben c'est l'amener à chercher comment on fait un argumentaire comme celui-là, essayer de l'écrire et puis analyser la production avec lui et voir ce dont il a besoin pour continuer à apprendre.
Donc c'est déjà amener l'élève à se mettre dans une dynamique d'engagement où il va lui-même s'engager dans la tâche, où il va par la suite lui-même voir les lacunes qu'il a et donc être
plus engagé dans le fait d'apprendre certains éléments.
Je dirais qu'aujourd'hui, le réel problème, et ça reboucle aussi sur ce dont on discutait à propos du pacte d'excellence, ce serait nécessaire d'avoir un changement systémique plutôt rapide,
mais que ce changement systémique plutôt rapide, il va être difficile à atteindre.
J'ai expliqué tout à l'heure pourquoi il était selon moi difficile à atteindre, mais pourquoi, à mon sens, c'est important d'avoir ce changement systémique, c'est que si on reste dans des innovations chez certains acteurs,
ces innovations ne vont pas survivre et les acteurs vont très vite s'arrêter.
Pour l'expliquer concrètement, aujourd'hui, notamment à l'université, lorsque des enseignants innovent,
par de nouvelles pédagogies, ce qu'on peut remarquer, c'est que les étudiants apprennent mieux, ont un apprentissage qui va être plus en profondeur, c'est-à-dire que
ce qu'ils apprennent, ils vont le retenir pendant plus longtemps et pouvoir le mobiliser plus longtemps par la suite.
Mais en termes de satisfaction, les élèves vont être moins satisfaits de ce type de cours parce que c'est en rupture par rapport au modèle qu'on explicitait juste avant.
C'est-à-dire que les élèves, enfin les étudiants, là, à l'université, préfèrent, de manière générale, aller s'asseoir dans un auditoire, écouter un enseignant,
étudier pendant deux ou trois jours un contenu pour réussir l'examen et ensuite l'oublier dans les semaines qui suivent, plutôt que de travailler tout au long de l'année dans des pédagogies qui vont être beaucoup plus par projet,
où la matière vient au fur et à mesure, où on leur demande de construire le savoir, etc.
et au final, avoir un résultat qui va être le même au niveau des examens. Mais vu qu'on est dans un système
où un à deux enseignants dans une année réalisent ce type d'expérience, et même si on a des meilleurs résultats, les élèves, eux, sont moins satisfaits.
Donc c'est là où je dis il faut un changement systémique. On voit qu'il y a des meilleurs résultats sur la qualité de l'apprentissage,
mais il faudrait que ce soit en quelque sorte pensé à un niveau beaucoup plus important et qu'il y ait un nombre plus important d'enseignants qui se mettent dans cette
dynamique-là pour que ça ait un réel effet et surtout pour que l'ensemble des acteurs s'y engagent.
Aujourd'hui, lorsque des enseignants s'y engagent, ils sont parfois confrontés, ben, à cette dimension où les étudiants sont moins satisfaits, où c'est difficile de se dire
: « OK, par la recherche, vous montrez qu'ils apprennent mieux, mais en même temps, ils sont moins contents de mon cours, donc qu'est-ce que je dois faire ? »
Pour revenir sur la question de l'efficacité, quand on regarde les écoles qui proposent une pédagogie alternative, enfin, elles sont très minoritaires, mais tout de même très intéressantes ici en Belgique francophone.
Quand on regarde ces écoles-là, est-ce qu'on remarque des chiffres, des performances, un taux de réussite fulgurant ou différent des autres écoles ?
Encore une fois, dans la dimension de l'efficacité, le problème, c'est pas nécessairement le résultat-
C'est les critères qu'on mesure.
C'est les critères, voilà, qu'on mesure. Quand on regarde des tests comme ceux même de PISA ou même les examens dits en Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, on a des choses qui sont très segmentées.
Et c'est pour ça que c'est facile de faire ce qu'on appelle du bachotage, de préparer ces élèves à réussir des examens comme ceux-là, parce qu'en fait, on est dans une forme de drill.
Et si on avait plutôt des questions problématiques et des problèmes qui vont nécessiter, face à une situation nouvelle, à l'élève de mobiliser un ensemble de savoirs, de savoir-faire, de savoir-être pour résoudre cette situation
plutôt que les mobiliser de manière morcelée, on peut là
mesurer l'efficacité de ces pédagogies-là.
Donc aujourd'hui, le souci pour moi, c'est qu'on va essayer d'évaluer des pédagogies alternatives, donc qui amènent des élèves à
à mobiliser ces savoirs, savoir-faire, savoir-être et qui,
tout d'un coup, pourraient être confrontés à des examens ou à des manières de mesurer ça, où les savoirs sont décontextualisés, savoir-faire et le savoir-être eux-mêmes sont décontextualisés.
Et là, c'est parfois ce qu'on va remarquer des élèves, notamment en arrivant à l'université, qui ont des difficultés pour réussir des examens de type questions à choix multiples.
Alors que ces élèves ont l'habitude de mobiliser un savoir, d'aller chercher lorsqu'ils ne savent pas, de remettre les choses en question, etc.
Tout d'un coup, on leur demande juste de recracher de la matière en fonction d'un ou deux mots qui changent, etc.
Mais quand tu parles de cette logique de restitution, de recracher la matière, on revient un petit peu au problème de la culture de l'émulation dont on parlait tout à l'heure.
Comment est-ce qu'on devient un professeur ? Ben en faisant exactement comme le professeur nous enseignait quand on était sur les bancs de l'école, etc.
Si c'est comme ça qu'on a toujours fonctionné, par cette culture de l'émulation, de recracher, de restituer la matière, finalement, la transition risque d'être très très très très lente.
Oui, et on le remarque, on le voit au-delà de l'école, dans ce que deviennent les élèves qui deviennent étudiants et qui deviennent ensuite employés ou entrepreneurs ou autres.
On remarque que cette culture se transforme, mais que la base reste la même. Pour donner un exemple concret qui commence à l'école, moi, quand je vais passer des questionnaires pour mes recherches et que je vais auprès
d'élèves déjà à 10 ans,
la première chose quand ils me voient avec mes feuilles, ils me disent bonjour, ça va, mais surtout, ils me demandent si c'est pour des points.
Donc il y a cette dimension dès qu'on donne quelque chose.
Si c'est pas pour des points, on s'en fout quoi.
Il y a ça, mais surtout, est-ce qu'on va être évalué ? Il y a une culture de l'évaluation qu'on appelle certificative, c'est-à-dire, on évalue souvent pour des points et pas pour apprendre.
Alors que depuis le plus jeune âge, on apprend en faisant, en quelque sorte, en expérimentant. Tout d'un coup, à l'école,
lorsqu'on va pouvoir expérimenter, tester les choses, lorsqu'on est confronté à des exercices, ben ces exercices, la plupart du temps, ils vont être évalués et ils vont être évalués pour des points qui vont avoir un impact sur la note, etc.
Et d'ailleurs, à l'école, malheureusement aujourd'hui, l'erreur n'est pas un outil pour apprendre. L'erreur, c'est vu comme l'échec.
Alors que l'erreur, ça peut être un outil qui nous permet de réfléchir : « Qu'est-ce qui a été bien fait ? Qu'est-ce qui a été mal fait ?
Pourquoi j'ai cette note-là ? » Et qui va me permettre de m'améliorer s'il y a un bon feedback. Et donc, pour qu'il y ait une bonne évaluation,
il faut que cette évaluation soit vécue positivement par l'élève, qu'il soit engagé, mais également qu'il y ait un feedback derrière l'évaluation.
C'est-à-dire que je sache pourquoi j'ai telle note ou telle note. Aujourd'hui, tout ça, 'fin, c'est peu présent dans le processus scolaire.
Ce qui fait que, ben on crée cette culture où on a peur de l'échec, notamment. On a peur de se tromper, on a peur de dire quelque chose qui n'est pas vrai.
'Fin, dans les amphis, lorsqu'on va poser une question aux étudiants, peu vont tenter de répondre parce qu'ils ont peur de donner une réponse qui serait la mauvaise réponse.
Alors que c'est-- moi, les mauvaises réponses, en quelque sorte, c'est celles que j'adore, parce que j'essaye de les amener à expliciter pourquoi ils ont donné cette réponse-là.
Et ça nous permet à tous et à toutes de réfléchir autour de cette réponse. Donc c'est hyper stimulant. Mais non, il y a cette peur de donner une mauvaise réponse.
Et donc finalement, oui, on est dans cette dimension de l'enseignement où on amène juste les élèves à apprendre ce qu'on leur enseigne et à être capable de recracher ce qu'on leur enseigne.
Finalement, ces élèves pour qui le système ne convient pas, c'est un petit peu comme si on essayait de faire rentrer un bloc rond à l'intérieur d'un bloc carré.
vraiment, pour ces gens-là, quelle est la solution pour ces élèves qui ne se retrouvent pas à l'intérieur d'un système qui, en plus de ne pas réussir à les former,
va un petit peu leur mettre la honte, va un petit peu les shame dans leurs difficultés, leur mettre une certaine culpabilité.
C'est de leur faute si ça ne se passe pas bien parce qu'ils ne veulent pas se conformer et se transformer en bloc carré.
Comment fait-on avec ces élèves-là qui sont en difficulté ?
Mais c'est là où l'innovation pédagogique et les pédagogies alternatives sont une piste de solution.
Mh.
Je dirais même où on refait la boucle avec le numérique.
Pour moi, c'est dans des pédagogies qui vont être beaucoup plus centrées sur les élèves, sur ce qu'ils ont envie d'apprendre, sur des méthodes qui vont également les valoriser, même dans l'échec, que les élèves
vont être plus prompts à apprendre.
Un exemple que j'aime beaucoup et qui est tiré de l'université : on a deux enseignants qui enseignaient en psychologie interculturelle.
Et chaque année, ils demandaient à leurs étudiants de faire un travail sur l'un de ces concepts. Et là, on avait des élèves qui faisaient un travail qui restait entre eux et l'enseignant.
Au mieux, les étudiants avaient un feedback, mais dans 95 % des cas, je n'ai pas eu de feedback, c'est-à-dire que je ne sais pas pourquoi j'ai eu telle ou telle note et quelles erreurs j'ai faites.
Donc ces enseignants ont commencé à réfléchir autour de tout ça. Et ce qu'ils ont mis en place : ils ont proposé aux étudiants de réaliser les pages Wikipédia de ces concepts en psycho interculturelle.
Et ça demande quoi ? D'écrire une page Wikipédia, de faire une revue de la littérature, pour ensuite synthétiser le contenu, le produire sur une forme qui va être également argumentée et pouvoir argumenter.
C'est-à-dire que lorsqu'on fait une page Wikipédia, on va faire des choix et dans le petit onglet Discussion, on va être attaqué ou remis en question par rapport à ces choix.
Et donc là, cet exemple-là, y a différents éléments qui interviennent derrière, qui ont motivé les étudiants. D'une part parce que c'est une tâche réelle.
Ils sont pas juste dans un travail entre eux et l'enseignant, ils sont sur une tâche qui a une plus-value parce qu'elle se fait dans la réalité et qu'elle a du sens pour eux.
Ils sont en train de constituer quelque chose qui est important, une page Wikipédia. Au-delà de ça, sans le faire et sans le dire directement, y a plein d'évaluations qu'on appelle formatives.
Lorsqu'ils vont publier, qu'ils vont être en discussion avec d'autres membres de Wikipédia parce qu'ils ont fait des choix sur l'une ou l'autre explication et qu'ils vont être amenés ou pas à changer leurs choix.
Mais les étudiants, ils sont évalués et ils sont amenés à réfléchir sur leur apprentissage. Et donc là, on a peut-être pas une pédagogie alternative, on est sur une pédagogie par projet, mais on amène les élèves à construire le savoir.
À aucun moment l'enseignant a enseigné ces concepts. Et surtout, il a ancré ça dans une tâche réelle. Et là, c'est une plus-value pour moi du numérique, mais on pourra y revenir par la suite. C'est qu'à
de nombreuses reprises,
le numérique et Internet en particulier va permettre d'ancrer des tâches scolaires dans le réel, de valoriser les élèves, mais aussi d'aller beaucoup plus loin dans cette évaluation et ce feedback que les élèves peuvent avoir.
On parle d'expérimenter de nouvelles techniques, de nouvelles façons d'enseigner dans un milieu qui est plutôt conservateur.
Donc je pense que c'est la dixième fois que je le répète, mais donc avec une certaine culture de l'émulation, on pense finalement à un modèle un plus libéral de l'école et de l'enseignement.
Et c'est finalement, je mets des gros guillemets quand je dis un modèle libéral hein, mais c'est finalement un petit peu à ça que ça ressemble quand le ministre Alexander De Croo
décide de créer ou de financer plutôt des structures d'enseignement de numérique, de programmation, de codage, etc., qui vont fonctionner en dehors de l'école et qui vont enseigner à des populations un peu moins favorisées, disons.
Par exemple, Molenbeek dans le cas de MolenGeek, avec qui tu as beaucoup pu travailler. Est-ce que tu peux nous parler un petit peu de ton expérience avec MolenGeek en tant que
structure qui n'est pas de l'enseignement obligatoire, qui n'est pas, voilà, qui ne vient pas du gouvernement ?
Oui, sans problème. Et juste une précision avec ça. Tout d'abord,
ce qui me paraît important par rapport à ces institutions alternatives, c'est lorsqu'elles sont elles-mêmes avec une volonté d'éduquer à l'esprit critique et à l'apprendre à apprendre et la capacité à se développer, à s'entreprendre soi-même.
Et c'est ce qu'on retrouve chez MolenGeek, sur lequel je vais revenir, mais on a aussi un ensemble de structures qui sont alternatives et qui vont former à des technologies propres ou à des manières de faire propres.
Et sans citer de marques, on a des grands noms du domaine du numérique-
On peut citer des marques hein, on n'est pas à la télévision.
Non, mais je veux pas me-
Ah oui, des sponsors, oui, d'accord. Des géants, des GAFAM.
Voilà, qui eux-mêmes se disent en faveur de l'éducation, amènent des activités dans le milieu de l'éducation.
Pour moi, ça pose un problème parce qu'on a tendance à les former, 'fin à former les élèves sur des outils qui sont des outils propres à ces entreprises et à les enfermer dans un cercle.
Et finalement, le Chromebook d'aujourd'hui est le manuel d'hier. On enferme la pensée dans certains outils qui, dans le cadre du Chromebook, sont les outils Google.
Chromebook ou le Surface Go ou le-
Voilà.
Le iPad Mini ou...
Voilà, et la suite Office 365 pour Microsoft et d'autres. Mais c'est de dire que quand ces géants investissent le domaine de l'éducation, ils le font pour des raisons parfois
philanthropiques, avec une certaine vision de l'éducation, mais enferment également dans leurs pro-- MolenGeek, qui est donc une école de codage située à Molenbeek, qui a des partenariats avec certaines de ces grandes entreprises,
elle vise l'émancipation des jeunes.
Et je crois que c'est ça qui est important.
C'est qu'on peut retrouver chez MolenGeek des pratiques qui sont très proches de l'entreprise, des pratiques pédagogiques qui tirent même appui sur ce qui se fait en entreprise, mais elles servent le développement du jeune.
C'est-à-dire que ces jeunes qui ont entre 18 et 25 ans, qui ont 6 mois de formation autour du développement, ce qu'ils apprennent, c'est certes des connaissances informatiques, des langages de programmation, etc.
Mais ce qu'ils apprennent surtout, c'est la capacité de continuer à apprendre, de continuer à apprendre de nouveaux langages, de continuer à se former, de continuer à travailler en équipe, etc.
Et donc, on les enferme pas, on leur rouvre les possibilités. C'est en ça que MolenGeek est l'antithèse, en quelque sorte, du système scolaire actuel.
C'est que plutôt que d'enfermer sur des contenus, sur une seule manière de transmettre le contenu, etc., chez MolenGeek, ce qu'on voit, c'est des pédagogies qui sont diversifiées.
Il y a du transmissif. À certains moments, on voit l'élève qui arrive comme un, 'fin, ou l'apprenant qui arrive comme un verre vide qu'on va remplir, mais pendant une heure ou deux.
Ensuite, on va lui proposer de travailler de manière collaborative. Ensuite, on va lui proposer de travailler sur un projet avec un client.
Ensuite, il va devoir, s'il a certaines compétences en plus que ses condisciples, il va devoir expliquer ce qu'il a appris à ses condisciples.
Et on voit que là, chez MolenGeek, ce qui fonctionne, c'est la diversité des pédagogies et avec cet objectif d'émancipation des apprenants.
Et ça, à mon sens, le système scolaire devrait pouvoir s'appuyer là-dessus, devrait pouvoir prendre ces pratiques-là.
C'est ce que nous disait le ministre quand je l'ai interviewé, c'est que son grand, sa grande ambition, entre guillemets, son rêve, c'est que le système scolaire classique
tire des leçons de ce qui est possible via ces acteurs comme MolenGeek, mais il y en a d'autres hein,
BeCode, et cetera.
Quand on me présente des choses comme ça, j'ai l'impression que ça ne m'a jamais arrivé et que y en a un qui est complètement inerte, statique et qui n'a pas envie de se remettre en question, qui est dans une culture de l'émulation.
Et y en a un autre qui répond à ce problème et aux failles de ce modèle-là en proposant une alternative.
Oui et non, dans le sens où je compare MolenGeek à tous ces enseignants, ils sont quand même nombreux au sein des écoles primaires, secondaires ou d'enseignement supérieur, qui font de l'innovation,
qui tentent des choses, qui ont des pédagogies eux-mêmes qui sont alternatives et qui ont plutôt des pratiques de pédagogie active centrées sur l'apprenant, et cetera.
C'est exactement la même chose. Ce sont des poches de résistance ou des poches d'innovation. Et d'ailleurs, on voit le problème,
entre guillemets, le problème chez MolenGeek, c'est que former de nouveaux formateurs à ces pratiques, ça prend du temps,
ça demande de l'accompagnement.
Et donc MolenGeek, jusqu'il y a peu, travaillait avec un seul formateur ou deux formateurs. L'idée de scaler, c'est-à-dire d'avoir plus de salles de classe, plus de formateurs, ça prend du temps.
Ça prend du temps, d'une part pour voir ce qui fonctionne, quelles sont les pratiques chez MolenGeek qui fonctionnent en termes de pédagogie et de résultats avec les apprenants, quelles sont les pratiques qui sont
à transférer aux autres apprenants, comment les transférer ?
Parce qu'on peut les connaître, mais il faut aussi être capable de transférer ces pratiques-là chez les autres formateurs et ensuite voir ce que ça donne sur le terrain.
Donc MolenGeek, certes, ça fonctionne, mais c'est parce que c'est quelques personnes qui ont cette magie et cette capacité à innover comme d'autres, 'fin comme des enseignants l'ont dans leur classe.
Et on pourrait se dire : « Si on faisait de ces enseignants, si on le faisait partout dans les salles de classe, et cetera, ça fonctionnerait.
» Oui, 'fin, oui, point d'interrogation. En tout cas, ça fonctionne pour leurs élèves.
Tu me dis que finalement, ça reste trop exceptionnel, trop... Voilà. C'est l'exception et pas la règle. Et ça ne peut pas devenir la règle.
Si, ça pourrait, mais j'dirais que ça demande ce fameux processus qui est long. Et c'est là toute la schizophrénie qui en quelque sorte peut m'habiter.
C'est de dire : faudrait un changement à la fois rapide et un peu radical en prenant certaines décisions, et en formant, si possible, très vite, je sais malheureusement pas comment, à faire, 'fin un changement,
un changement qui amène à beaucoup plus de pédagogie active, centrée sur les apprenants, avec beaucoup plus d'innovation autour du numérique, notamment, mais également avec d'autres méthodes pédagogiques.
Et de l'autre côté, ce changement qui est lent, à la fois parce qu'il y a un conservatisme des acteurs, mais pas que ça, c'est pas que ça, c'est la formation des acteurs qui est très longue.
Et oui, le système scolaire, c'est un gros bateau. Quand on voit juste chez MolenGeek, pour les prendre en exemple, le fait de former de nouveaux formateurs, le temps que ça prend et c'est juste quelques personnes.
Si on voit ça à l'échelle du système scolaire, mais oui, on est dans des temps qui-
C'est sûr, ouais.
...qui se démultiplient.
Tu parles des temps de formation.
Un des éléments qui est frappant quand on enquête un petit peu sur ce domaine, c'est que on a d'un côté le ministère de l'Enseignement obligatoire et de l'autre côté, le ministère de l'Enseignement supérieur.
Y en a un qui forme les acteurs de l'autre. Le ministère de l'Enseignement supérieur forme les professeurs qui vont enseigner au sein de l'enseignement obligatoire.
Donc finalement, on a
deux ministères. Pour l'instant, dans le gouvernement actuel, le gouvernement de la Fédération Wallonie-Bruxelles, pas dans le même parti politique, même s'ils sont dans la même majorité,
que donc ils doivent vraiment tomber d'accord et travailler ensemble alors qu'ils sont issus de familles politiques différentes pour réussir à faire une réforme efficace.
C'est exactement ça. Et en fait, derrière mon propos tout à l'heure, les auditeurs pourront
retourner à ce passage où je disais : « J'espère qu'il y a une cohérence entre le pacte d'excellence et la réforme autour de la formation initiale des enseignants.
» C'est typiquement à cause de cette dimension-là où le pacte d'excellence est géré par la ministre Marie-Martine Schyns,
qui est CDH et de l'autre côté, le ministère de l'Enseignement supérieur, qui est géré par le ministre Jean-Claude Marcourt, qui est PS.
Et donc là, on a deux ministères gérés par deux partis politiques différents, des ministères qui sont parfois pas d'accord entre eux.
Et c'est, 'fin, la formation initiale des enseignants, ça fait près de cinq ans que des acteurs, voire même plus, mais au moins cinq ans, que des acteurs y travaillent et on n'a pas encore de consensus établi.
Alors, on dit toujours qu'on arrive au bout. Pour l'instant, le bout, il prend encore un peu de temps. Et dans ce travail d'accompagnement,
on travaille sur la manière de remodeler la pédagogie et de travailler la pédagogie des enseignants.
Et c'est encore plus vrai dans le milieu dans lequel j'évolue principalement, qui est l'enseignement supérieur. L'enseignement supérieur où les enseignants qui enseignent n'ont pas de background pédagogique.
Donc les enseignants à l'université sont sélectionnés par rapport à leurs travaux de recherche, sont même évalués et promus en fonction de leurs travaux de recherche, très peu sur les dimensions d'enseignement.
Les professeurs d'université sont donc avant tout des chercheurs et pas des professeurs.
Voilà. Et donc, dans l'équipe que je dirige,
l'utilisation et l'intégration du numérique, c'est aussi une manière pour travailler avec ces enseignants sur leurs cours, sur la manière dont ils enseignent, sur les problématiques qu'ils rencontrent au quotidien,
de motivation de leurs élèves, de présence au cours de leurs étudiants, de manières d'enseigner à cette génération d'étudiants.
Donc, le numérique, c'est un peu, comme je le disais, notre cheval de Troie
pour amener les enseignants à se poser des questions sur la manière dont ils enseignent, sur les pratiques pédagogiques plus efficaces et sur celles qui vont favoriser de meilleurs apprentissages chez leurs élèves.
Si on essaie de regarder l'aspect temporel, est-ce que tu penses que d'ici 2030, on aura des écoles où le numérique sera proprement intégré ?
Je te demande pas de prédire la forme que ça prendra. Ça pourrait être du bring your own device, ça pourrait être des podcasts, ça pourrait être des tableaux blancs interactifs bien utilisés.
Est-ce qu'on aura sérieusement entamé cette transition d'ici 12 ans, tu penses ?
Je l'espère.
D'accord.
Et pour y répondre concrètement en deux temps. D'une part, c'est intéressant que tu donnes cette date parce que c'est aussi
au sein de l'Université Libre de Bruxelles une réflexion qui est en cours avec un projet qui s'appelle CAP 2030, qui est la volonté de réfléchir
à ce que sera l'université à horizon de l'année 2030 et donc de développer un plan stratégique qui pourra mettre en œuvre les actions à atteindre d'ici 2030. Et une des,
des réflexions en cours, je ne sais pas si elle se réalisera, mais en tout cas, c'est l'intégration de beaucoup plus de numérique au sein de cet enseignement supérieur, avec beaucoup plus d'enseignement à la fois en ligne et d'enseignement hybride, donc
d'un cursus qui dépasse uniquement et qui réduit le présentiel, avec beaucoup plus d'enseignement et d'apprentissage à distance, avec un espace physique qui va être aussi beaucoup plus pensé pour du présentiel qui intègre le numérique.
C'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui, les amphithéâtres en rang d'oignon sans prise de courant avec un Wi-Fi qui ne dépasse pas 40 utilisateurs pour des salles de 600 à 700 étudiants, c'est un peu moyen.
Donc y a toute une réflexion qui va avec cette transformation de la pédagogie qui doit aller, qui doit se faire sur l'espace physique, mais également l'espace,
en ligne avec des plateformes qui vont répondre aux besoins des enseignants et surtout des étudiants de pouvoir travailler en groupe, de travailler en partageant des documents, etc., etc.,
sans utiliser les produits de nos chers GAFA.
D'accord. Maintenant qu'on a bien compris que ça allait demander des investissements financiers en termes d'outils, etc., mais en termes de timing, est-ce que 2030, ça te semble optimiste ?
Autant j'ai l'impression qu'une institution comme l'Université Libre de Bruxelles peut y arriver par sa taille et sa capacité à mettre les choses en œuvre parce qu'elle n'a qu'un corps enseignant de quelques milliers d'enseignants.
Pour le système scolaire, encore une fois, ça va être beaucoup plus compliqué. 'Fin, pour l'enseignement obligatoire, je veux dire,
ça va être, à mon sens, beaucoup plus compliqué
parce que ça va demander un accompagnement beaucoup plus important, des investissements matériels beaucoup plus importants, des transformations de pratiques qui vont prendre beaucoup plus de temps. Et donc tout ça
peut dépasser pour moi le cap de l'année 2030. Et si sur le papier, des choses se font, tu parlais du bring your own device, c'est-à-dire se dire : aujourd'hui, tout élève a dans sa poche
un outil qu'il pourrait utiliser à des fins d'enseignement et d'apprentissage, c'est-à-dire son smartphone, qu'il pourrait utiliser pour faire des recherches d'informations dans le cadre d'activités de classe, pour faire du vote en ligne
pendant la classe et plein d'autres choses.
Certes, ça peut se faire très rapidement, mais derrière, ça va demander aux enseignants de maîtriser les outils numériques.
Y a une pléthore d'outils de type smartphone, de marques différentes, etc. Et donc ça va demander une acculturation numérique des enseignants qui va également prendre du temps.
Autant ça pourrait se faire du jour au lendemain chez certains enseignants, autant ça va prendre du temps. Et c'est là où se dire 2030 que tout est changé, j'espère que...
Les écoles qui auront fait cette transition, finalement, ce seront lesquelles ? Est-ce que ce seront juste les écoles de riches avant celles qui sont peut-être moins privilégiées ?
Non, je pense que ce seront des écoles où des enseignants innovants accepteront plus facilement de partager leur savoir et que d'autres enseignants seront réceptifs-
D'accord.
...à ça. Malheureusement, aujourd'hui, souvent, enseigner, c'est enseigner porte close, sans partager la manière dont on enseigne.
Je pense que pour que cette transformation se fasse, il faut l'émergence de ce qu'on appelle des communautés de pratique.
Et ne serait-ce qu'au sein des écoles, que les enseignants échangent sur ce qu'ils font, sur la manière dont ils enseignent et sur l'efficacité de leurs pratiques.
On sait que l'importance de l'école dépend très fort du contexte dans lequel elle existe, contexte économique, entre autres.
N'a, par exemple, pas du tout la même importance au Maghreb et en Belgique, puisqu'il y aura là-bas une fonction beaucoup plus concrète.
Il faut que je travaille pour avoir un beau métier et ramener du pain sur la table.
Là où en Belgique, on sera beaucoup plus dans un contexte, on cherchera davantage à suivre une voie qui correspond à sa personnalité, à qui on souhaite devenir.
Dans un monde qui s'apprête à être complètement révolutionné par l'intelligence artificielle, où nombre de métiers dits simples vont disparaître, on pense aux comptables, par exemple,
est-ce que la fonction de l'école n'en devient pas transformée ?
Est-ce que, finalement, on ne doit pas former les gens à des aspects qu'une machine ne saurait pas maîtriser ?
Oui, mais on revient finalement sur ces dimensions où on ne forme pas l'élève et la pédagogie ne doit pas être transmissive.
C'est-à-dire que derrière cette pédagogie transmissive, ce qu'on va évaluer chez l'élève, c'est sa capacité à recracher le savoir qu'il a appris.
Donc ça, en effet, une machine pourrait très facilement prendre ce rôle-là. Par contre, de résoudre des problèmes complexes qui vont nécessiter d'analyser la situation,
qui vont nécessiter de mobiliser des savoirs, des savoir-faire, des savoir-être,
et de mobiliser un ensemble de choses pour répondre à des situations nouvelles.
Certes, peu à peu, l'intelligence artificielle, dans un certain nombre de cas, pourra le faire.
Mais là, on éduque également les élèves, non pas à des matières précises, non pas à des thématiques précises, mais aussi à être, encore une fois, capables d'apprendre à apprendre et à se renouveler.
Et à la limite, s'ils ont commencé en étant comptable et qu'ils voient que l'intelligence artificielle les supplante, alors, c'est un grand mot, mais déjà, ils vont pouvoir se dire : « Ben ok, si la technologie s'occupe de ça,
ben qu'est-ce que je vais pouvoir faire en plus ou comment je vais pouvoir enseigner, 'fin,
faire mon métier différemment ?
» Et donc, si on forme des bons petits soldats juste capables de recracher du savoir, en effet, ils courent à leur perte.
Si on les rend capables de continuer à apprendre, d'analyser la situation,
de pouvoir en faire une estimation pertinente et de pouvoir créer de nouvelles connaissances, de pouvoir continuer à apprendre, là, on pourra s'appuyer sur cette intelligence artificielle pour en faire beaucoup plus.
Donc finalement, la transition d'un enseignement de restitution à on va émettre une pensée critique, une méthode scientifique.
Ça me paraît assez essentiel, enfin, d'après ce que tu dis, face à l'arrivée de l'intelligence artificielle dans notre économie.
Oui, entièrement.
J'ai envie de reparler, de revenir justement sur cet aspect de restitution. Est-ce que,
et alors bon, je fais une petite fixette hein, je suis désolé, mais est-ce que la Belgique est plus que les autres pays, que les autres cultures dans ce mode de fonctionnement, de restitution, de recracher la matière ?
Est-ce qu'on est finalement comme les autres ? Est-ce qu'on est différent à ce niveau-là ?
Je dirais qu'en tout cas, dans les pays qui nous entourent, et je pense notamment à la France, on est un peu comme eux, dans le sens où même si eux
ont notamment une culture philosophique plus importante et on forme à l'argumentation et à l'analyse philosophique, on va voir qu'on forme à une méthode qu'on doit être capable d'appliquer à soi, etc.
Et donc même dans cette idée d'esprit critique, c'est tout de même l'esprit critique dans une certaine démarche et avec une certaine méthode.
Mais à côté de ça, certes, les pays du Nord sont souvent vus comme un eldorado pédagogique. Et je pense que le point de départ de cet eldorado pédagogique, ça a été cette transition radicale.
Je sais plus si c'est dans les années 70, 80,
où notamment la Finlande a fait ce choix de
transformer son système scolaire,
d'y introduire un tronc commun, d'y introduire une plus grande diversité de matières, de voir comment ces matières pouvaient servir les élèves à devenir
une personne avec un socle commun à 16, 17 ans, pour ensuite faire un choix qui est valorisé, qu'il soit vers le professionnel ou vers un choix qui est plus,
universitaire.
Et donc c'est un choix, 'fin, c'est ce changement qui a été fait de manière radicale dont on pourrait s'inspirer.
Je trouve que, de manière générale, on a tendance à observer plutôt les impacts de ce choix, les changements, et à bêtement, entre guillemets, essayer de reproduire ce tronc commun, la manière dont ils font la pédagogie, etc.
Et qu'on n'a pas assez observé la manière dont ils ont opéré cette transformation radicale et que c'est plutôt là qu'on pourrait tirer
de quoi faire notre propre transformation et inspirer plus probablement le pacte d'excellence.
Et donc là, oui, il y a une différence, mais je pense pas que-- je sais pas si cette différence est liée à la culture, également à des aspects de démographie,
de géographie et de déplacement des populations et de difficultés de déplacement, etc.
Ce qui, notamment au Québec, a créé l'enseignement à distance. C'était cette difficulté, parfois, vu les conditions météorologiques, de rejoindre les établissements scolaires.
Donc y a beaucoup plus d'histoire géographique, démographique, culturelle, que juste se dire : « Ah, mais c'est une culture qui est différente.
» C'est-- ou alors c'est la culture dans tout son côté aussi historique, etc., qui crée ça, mais...
C'est difficile de cerner effectivement l'impact de toute une histoire, de toute une culture et son impact sur ces questions-là, oui.
Très bien. Nicolas, est-ce que tu souhaites rajouter quelque chose avant qu'on se quitte ?
Un dernier message dont on n'a pas du tout parlé et qui est un de mes chevaux de bataille.
Je t'en prie, vas-y.
Je vais quand même juste le souligner pour les personnes qui nous écoutent.
C'est l'autre schizophrénie, au-delà de celle dont je parlais tout à l'heure, l'autre schizophrénie qui m'habite aujourd'hui, c'est
tout ce qui concerne les inégalités numériques et le fait qu'aujourd'hui, lorsqu'on va introduire du numérique dans le système scolaire, que ce soit l'enseignement obligatoire ou l'enseignement supérieur,
on va voir qu'on va introduire des inégalités entre les élèves.
Parce qu'il y a des élèves qui vont être capables de maîtriser ces outils numériques et ceux qui
ne vont pas être capables de maîtriser ces outils numériques pour réaliser les tâches qu'on leur demande, que ce soit en termes de recherche d'informations, de production multimédiatique, etc.
Donc aujourd'hui, j'ai beaucoup parlé de la formation et de l'accompagnement des enseignants. Je pense qu'il est également très important, au-delà d'utiliser le numérique,
du côté des enseignants pour réaliser un ensemble d'activités pédagogiques, c'est également important de former les élèves à ce dont je parlais tout à l'heure, la littératie médiatique numérique
et aux compétences numériques pour qu'ils soient capables d'être des citoyens qui évoluent dans le monde qui est celui d'aujourd'hui.
On part un petit peu du principe qu'il y a des digital natives et que y en a d'autres qui ne le sont pas du tout. Et alors que finalement...
Oui, je dirais même que la croyance populaire, et c'est quelque chose qu'on a observé dans certaines recherches,
donc c'est pas qu'une-- 'fin, c'est une croyance populaire qui se matérialise dans les réponses des enseignants,
mais c'est que ces digital natives existent et qu'ils,
qu'ils sont compétents parce que les jeunes étant nés dans ce bain de numérique et on les voit utiliser leurs outils numériques toute la journée, on se dit qu'ils les maîtrisent et qu'on
peut prendre appui là-dessus pour faire des activités pédagogiques. Non.
Puisqu'ils utilisent Snapchat, ils doivent être doués pour faire un Google Docs, un-- collaborer sur un travail ensemble.
Voilà. Et malheureusement, faire, ben comme tu le dis, un document collaboratif sur Google Docs, ça va demander des compétences techniques.
Alors déjà, ouvrir un Google Docs, comprendre comment ça fonctionne, etc. Ça ressemble à un traitement de texte, donc ça va.
Même si ça étonne toujours, même des étudiants à l'université, de voir que techniquement, plusieurs personnes écrivent en même temps.
C'est toujours un côté magique pour certains.
On parle même donc d'étudiants à l'université qui ont 18, 19, 20 ans et qui débarquent complètement en essayant Google Docs pour la première fois.
Oui, alors, c'est dans le meilleur des cas. 'Fin, dans le meilleur des cas, ils le connaissent, ça, c'est 5 %. Dans une petite majorité, ils ne le...
'Fin, ils se disent : « Ah oui, c'est possible. » Et ils ouvrent des grands yeux. Et dans la grande majorité, ils ne connaissent pas ces outils.
Donc aujourd'hui, les étudiants qui arrivent à l'université-
Une petite majorité, une grande majorité, ça fonctionne comment, ça ?
Alors, je pourrais donner des chiffres plus importants, mais qui dépendent parfois des facultés, des années, etc.
Mais on va dire que dans une grande majorité, les étudiants se disent que ce n'est pas possible, que-- enfin que ça n'existe pas.
J'ai l'impression que d'après ce que tu dis, même ceux qui ont déjà essayé, connaissent déjà un petit peu, ne se le sont pas vraiment approprié et n'auront jamais l'initiative de l'utiliser par eux-mêmes.
Voilà. Et alors, ça demande des dimensions aussi. Je parlais du technique, mais de rédaction. Comment on rédige quand on est à plusieurs sur une même feuille ?
Qui a la priorité ? Qui on laisse écrire en premier ? Est-ce qu'on corrige, etc. ? Ça demande des dimensions organisationnelles, etc.
auxquelles les étudiants n'ont jamais pensé-
D'accord.
...auxquelles ils doivent faire face tout d'un coup, en maîtrisant aussi une dimension technique qu'ils comprennent pas nécessairement, avec des aspects de couleurs ou aussi de pouvoir réorganiser l'information, qui--
dont ils ne prennent pas conscience parce qu'ils ne connaissent pas l'outil.
Et donc c'est ça que ça pose comme problème. Au mieux, je dirais que les étudiants qui arrivent à l'université par rapport à cet outil-là, ben ils l'ont utilisé seuls pour réaliser un travail.
Ils se disaient que ça avait l'air intéressant de faire ça sur Google Docs plutôt que de le faire sur Microsoft Word, mais ils n'ont pas utilisé les dimensions collaboratives.
Et ces dimensions collaboratives entraînent de nouvelles dimensions à comprendre.
De nouveaux usages, ouais, ouais.
Et il faut former les étudiants.
D'accord. On a bien compris que un de tes grands chevaux de bataille, c'était, voilà, la formation au numérique, de ne pas présumer qu'elle se fera par elle-même, la faire tant au niveau des étudiants, des élèves que,
du corps professoral et des enseignants.
Également révolutionner un petit peu la pédagogie, ne pas faire que de la restitution et aussi, voilà, chercher à faire une méthode scientifique, une pensée critique, une, voilà, quelque chose d'un peu plus,
un peu plus spontané, un peu plus personnel, plutôt que de juste, voilà, recracher la matière.
Très bien. Nicolas Roland, merci, c'était un plaisir.
Merci à toi.
Et on se retrouve bientôt pour un nouvel épisode. Bye bye. Et c'est déjà tout pour ce cinquième épisode. Comme je le disais en début d'émission, on a enregistré ce podcast cet été.
Et Nicolas a depuis quitté ses fonctions à l'ULB pour faire de la consultance, toujours dans le domaine de la science de l'éducation.
Pour suivre Nicolas ou pour me suivre moi sur Twitter, il y a un lien dans la description et il y a aussi des liens vers tous les réseaux sociaux.
Encore une fois, je vous invite à aller faire un tour dessus, à liker la page et à partager les extraits des émissions qui vous ont plu.
N'hésitez pas non plus à revenir vers moi. J'adore vraiment entendre vos retours. Allez, on se retrouve dans deux semaines.